troubling new details about how uber
responded to a massive hack attack raise
questions about the way it handled
sensitive customer information in an
exclusive interview the US attorney who
investigated the 2016 hack detailed how
uber handled the theft of data from tens
of millions of users and the very
different response from LinkedIn after a
similar cyber theft
this comes as to hackers pleaded guilty
yesterday Kris Van Cleave is in
Washington Chris
what does uber say about this case well
good morning when uber finally
acknowledged this hack its new CEO said
this never should have happened but in
2016 when it happened uber was a very
different company and back then its
executives did not want this data breach
to become public so they paid off the
hackers and then tracked them down but
not to turn them in prosecutors say uber
launched its own version of a manhunt to
track down the two twenty-something
hackers that extorted the company out of
$100,000 in exchange for a promise to
delete 57 million user files they stole
off a third party server the Justice
Department says within weeks of paying
the ransom
uber employees showed up at Brandon
Glover's Winter Park Florida home and
found viselli Mary car at a hotel
restaurant in Toronto Canada the pair
admitted their crimes but uber didn't
turn them over to the cops instead they
had the hackers signed non-disclosure
agreements promising to keep quiet do
you feel that uber acted responsibly
absolutely not
Dave Anderson is the US attorney for the
Northern District of California have you
seen a company ask for an NDA from
people who have ripped them off before I
can't think of another case that offices
handled that has that dimension to it
this case is extraordinary in that
regard do you know what was done with
that data after they paid not
definitively and there's no way to know
definitively we know that the defendants
said that they destroyed that data but
there was a third participant in the
hack and that third participant was
unknown to over the hackers also
targeted a company owned by LinkedIn in
December of 2016
but prosecutors say LinkedIn did not pay
and promptly reported the hack to police
uber eventually did as well a year after
the hack new CEO derek has rashi
publicly disclosed the attack we talked
to him in 2018 one of your biggest
challenges as CEO was coming into a
company that had a culture that many
thought was broken and fixing that
culture changing that culture has that
change happened fast enough so I think
we've definitely made steps in the right
direction but the work of culture is
never done are we gonna make mistakes
yep but are we gonna get better every
year
absolutely the two hackers were
eventually arrested and pleaded guilty
on Wednesday to conspiracy to commit
extortion uber behaved atrociously wired
editor-in-chief Nick Thompson says with
cyber crimes on the rise our personal
data remains vulnerable we've come up
with all kinds of smart ways to protect
data and hackers have come up with all
kinds of smart ways to get through our
protections your data is held in a bunch
of places and each one of those places
needs to be secure the first time those
two hackers met in person was after they
were arrested they now face a maximum of
five years in prison that third person
involved remains at large now uber said
it cannot comment on an ongoing criminal
investigation last year the company
settled with the FTC and paid 148
million dollars to settle a nationwide
investigation brought by state attorneys
general over this hack Gail that's a big
number thank you very much Chris